coped 19 continues to also impact the
hispanic community across the valley
the area hardest hit is in east las
vegas joe muller joining us now live
near charleston and eastern with the
message from one organization that's
trying to help
joe hey there denise yeah east las vegas
has had a hard fight with the
coronavirus zip codes in this area have
had
a lot more cases compared to other areas
across the valley so right now people
are urged to wear their masks
more than ever that worries me my family
the hispanic population continues to be
hit hard by the coronavirus
now making up nearly 40 percent of all
cases it's definitely frightening i mean
i grew up in
that zip code a9110 you know east las
vegas a heavily populated hispanic area
is seeing the most cases
area code 89110 has had more than 4400
cases alone
116 of which were in the past seven days
maria nieto orta from the family of
volta says people can't forget
we are in a pandemic it's very important
for us to keep reminding the community
like
hey the pandemic is still here like it's
still very much going on and
the cases are going up higher every time
someone kind of lets their guard down
about it so it's definitely frightening
so just making sure we're still telling
the community to wear masks
nieto orta says the estantos manos
campaign is still in full swing and
wants people to know
me family evolta is continuing grocery
delivery for people who have tested
positive to keep them from leaving their
home
we have helped over 700 families now so
far i probably like the numbers probably
800 now
we spoke to those who live in east las
vegas i'll put the mask on you know
i don't want anybody to get sick i
believe it's real
residents know it is a problem in the
area and wearing a mask is important
just him not wearing them and if they're
wearing it they got it on their chin
back out here live the estancias manos
campaign is still working to spread
awareness here in east las vegas
especially the zip codes that were hit
hard
they regularly post online on facebook
some testing locations around the valley
reporting live in east las vegas joe
allen 8 news now